(crowd stomping and clapping)
- Enjoy the show guys.
- For sure.
- Alright boys, let's focus up, okay?
I say we start off the set
tonight with Rat Poison, alright,
and then we end it with Pussy Thunder.
- I just want to say, I'm
stoked to be here with you guys,
right now, right here.
- Fellas, you're on in five.
- Thanks, Lou.
- This is the big show.
- Let's tear it up.
- Bring it in.
- No matter what happens--
- [Man in Glasses] Yeah.
- [Woman] Let's remember
where we started, right here
in this green room, as best friends.
(cheery folk music)
- Rat Taxi.
- Rat Taxi!
(stomping and clapping)
- Hi.
- Oh, hey guys.
- Sara.
- Over here.
- We made a series.
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here, over here.
- [Sara] There.
- [Woman Far Left] Over there, you got it.
I think you got it, okay, I'm out.
- [Sara] Okay Bye!
It will be released 2015, November.
- [Voiceover] Quinta!
- Okay.